seulement 3500 personnes pourront être
présente au centre bell ce soir comme
lors des matches précédents dans un
événement qui peut contenir 21 mille
spectateurs l'ambiance représente un
défi important
on en discute avec jean olivier dalphond
président de pécs mom qui illumine les
sièges vacants
bonjour monsieur dalphond bonjour alors
votre entreprise a le mandat de faire
oublier l'absence de milliers de
spectateurs c'est tout le mandat
comment l'avez vous abordez vous ces
pics mob on a utilisé des sièges qui
étaient vides pour en fait amplifié
l'énergie des gens qui sont dans la
foule et de la création que le canadien
au fait au niveau du jeu vidéo et de la
musique pour combiner ça donc c'est
vraiment une amplification l'énergie
qu'il est ce que ces boues qui avait
approché le canadien c'est eux
est ce que c'est une occasion vous
attendez pour pouvoir travailler avec
lui on s'était parlé d'eux pendant
plusieurs années mais cette année c'est
nous qui leur ont approché parce que
durant la pandémie
nous avons développé une technologie
pour utiliser sur les sièges qui étaient
vides parce que les arénas si nos lieux
de travail
mais c'était devenu parce que des villes
fantômes donc on se dit qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour les rendre vivantes à
nouveau et on a développé ce que vous
allez voir sur les sièges ce soir si ce
qui est ce que c'est dans les mains
sûres alors la grande question c'est de
savoir à quel point est ce que l'équipe
va bénéficier de l'effet de la foule
rien ne peut à montréal
est-ce que vous avez l'impression quand
même que vos illuminations vont aider
les joueurs du canadien ce soir je crois
que oui j'ai vu des pratiques et des et
on sentait quelque chose encore dans
l'espace parce qu'on regarde et la
lumière ce problème
il ya beaucoup d'intensité donc quand on
est sur la glace on peut pas ne pas le
voir
et dès qu'il a un moment fort mais nous
on est là pour l'amplifier
je crois que ça va il s'arrête
définitivement un petit jeu on pique
smob peut-être que certains ont noté des
spectateurs vous découvre avec le
canadien mais vous avez illuminé
de nombreux événements les jeux
olympiques de sotchi la mi-temps du
superbowl est là maintenant vous êtes
avec le canadien comment comme
entreprise on se retrouve à être aussi
présent dans des événements
internationaux
ce que j'aime dire c'est pour faire ces
événements au lof pour par exemple faire
la mi-temps du superbowl où le canadien
il faut traiter chacun des éléments
qu'on fait comme si c'était le sport
boules à mites où l'événement des
canadiens ou les olympiques
et lorsque c'est le temps de parler avec
les canadiens en fait nous on a fait
trente heures entre le moment où on
indigo et l'exécution et y ont dit on
ferait probablement passé avec d'autres
compagnies mais on reconnaît on connaît
votre réputation et donc il dit ont fait
confiance
allez-y alors c'était une belle marque
de confiance une belle collaboration
montréal à ce moment là mais la 30
heures pour vos employés vos équipes
comment ça s'est passé et puis on peut
dormir beaucoup j'imagine mais on est
habitué parce que le monde du spectacle
c'est c'est comme ça et ils ont dormi
ils ont travaillé fort aujourd'hui dans
les estrades 100 belge au lycée lui
d'ailleurs pour cette exprimé fort mais
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
régulièrement dans les arénas on a
presque tout fait léser les rennais de
la mairie du mans donc on est on est
habitués et et on aime ça nous manque et
l'événementiel comment est-ce que vous
en est devenu lé fondateur de pixmania
dans ce créneau lorsque c'est parce que
vous aimiez les spectacles les grands
événements comme on sait qu'on peut la
genèse de l'entreprise
c'est vraiment l'innovation donc c'est
l'innovation et les expériences de foule
comment est-ce qu'on peut créer une
énergie entre les gens et dans qui sont
proches de lui comme est-ce qu'on peut
réussir à elvis c'est vraiment ce qui a
motivé la création des pics mob et son
déploiement est toujours essayer de
trouver comment est-ce qu'on peut le
faire mieux comment est-ce qu'on peut
inventer ça parce que notre but a
toujours été de pousser plus loin et
d'inventer la prochaine chose qui fait
en sorte que lorsqu'on vit dans un
spectacle de cette énergie collective le
quai comme ok je suis ici mais pas
seulement
le
l'artiste et la chanson et la musique
mais nous comment est-ce qu'on peut
amplifier ce tout le temps monté d'une
coche en jeu mais comment est-ce qu'on
reste à jour parce que toujours des
développements technologiques vous avez
pas par un certain moment d'être dépassé
par les autres technologies alors au
contraire nous on adore ça parce que
c'est justement lorsqu'on va chercher
des choses qui sont fondamentales qui
viennent de sortir sur les marchés et
puis nous on va les utiliser parce qu'on
construit tout de a à z
ici au québec donc on est extrêmement
excité parce que l'on voit des
opportunités que d'autres personnes dans
le marché pourrait pas voir puisque nous
c'est vraiment là on a contre c'est très
excitant
vous avez travaillé sur un peu plus
d'une quarantaine dans d une quarantaine
de pays de très nombreux projets quels
sont vos plans pour les prochaines
années comment est ce que vous voyez
l'entreprise évolué nous ce qu'on
aimerait c'est que chacun des spectacles
ultime en est quelque chose qui est
unique à lui que ce soit un artiste qui
est un bracelet qui est spécifiquement à
lui donc ré vraiment c'est quelque chose
qui est de plus en plus unique à chacun
des événements et continuer on ne fait
car en payer mais il y en a beaucoup
plus sur la planète donc je voudrais
qu'on a des ambitions encore plus grande
ou est ce qu'on veux pas vous voir la
prochaine fois à part les canadiens la
semaine prochaine le ufc une un combat à
las vegas alary qui réserve du pic ce
mot là dessus et et bien d'autres d'ici
la fin de l'année vérité mais merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
eq les et merci au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i cirdi
oh